not everything in life is an
economic transaction it ultimately is
close
but even if it's not an economic
transaction even if it's a if it's a
it's a relationship transaction
when you get to a point with a friend
where you're not gaining from the
relationship
friendship's going to be over not
immediately because it takes time for
these things to manifest itself and to
really absorb into
but we change friendships we change our
loves right we fall in and out of love
we fall out of love because we're not
love
so let's let's go back to love right
love is the most selfish of all emotions
love is about what you do to me right so
i love my wife because she makes me feel
better about myself
yeah so you know the idea of selfless
love is bizarre
so ein man used to say before you say i
love you
you have to say the i
you you have to know who you are and you
have to appreciate yourself
if you hate yourself what does it mean
to love somebody else
so my i love my wife because she makes
me feel great about the world
yeah and she lives me for the same
reason
and so iran used to use this example
imagine you go up to your uh to be
spouse the night before the wedding
and you say you know i get nothing out
of this relationship
i'm doing this purely as an act of noble
self-sacrifice
she would slap you yeah as she should
right
so no we know this intuitively that love
is selfish but we afraid to admit it to
ourselves and why
because the other side has convinced us
that selfishness is associated with
exploiting other people
selfishness means lying cheating
stealing walking
corpses backstabbing people
but is that ever in your self-interest
truly
right i you know i i'll often be in
front of an audience to say okay how
many people here have lied
you know kidding right how many of you
think that
that if you did that consistently that
would make your life
better nobody thinks that right
because everybody's experienced how
shitty
lying not because of how it makes you
feel out of a sense of guilt
existentially just a bad strategy yeah
right you get
caught you have to create other lies to
cover up the previous lie
it screws up with your own psychology
and your own cognition
you know the mind to some extent like a
computer right
is an integrating machine and in
computer science i understand there's a
term called garbage in garbage out
lying is garbage in yeah so
it's not good strategy cheating uh
screwing your customers in a business
not paying your suppliers as a
businessman
not good business practices not good
practices for being alive
so win-win is both moral and practical
and the beauty of iron man's philosophy
and i think this is really important is
that the model is the practical and the
practicalism all
and therefore if you are model you will
be happy
you